all right randy and stephen
where are you guys from originally
randy i'm from here i'm from charleston
in stephen where do you grow up i'm from
uh pokken like toy area so just north of
here yeah yeah and uh what were your
childhoods like
um
i mean mine was mom was actually pretty
chaotic you know i just had a mother
growing up who was you know my mom was
uh addicted to crack growing up so it
was kind of just me and my brother my
mother brother my little sister
and i kind of raised them and
like growing up like my mom was always
kind of like my best friend so i kind of
had a chaotic childhood
you got chaotic yeah yeah no abuse or
anything but just nuts i mean like in
the beginning there was a little bit of
abuse like from some of her boyfriends
and stuff like that but as i got older
that kind of went away there was sexual
abuse i mean a little bit yeah yeah when
i was younger like maybe when i was like
five or six that's what i'm saying i
don't think i was ever technically a
virgin and that sounds terrible but yeah
i don't think i ever actually was
and stephen how'd you grow up
well
it was this me my mom and my stepdad um
30 years he just passed away last year
from lung cancer room
i was beat up every day
going against the wall born
hungry fans all kinds of stuff i got
scars all over me from childhood people
look at the exterior they don't see them
the past
um i was sexually abused by my brothers
starting
my little brother was starting about
eight nine ten
and every time i would go talk to my mom
and my dad
stepped out about i was lying because
they didn't want to believe it but they
knew what was going on
and it wasn't until my
little niece come forward and said she
was sexually abused by my brother's own
kid by him
and
my family's
i was thrown out because i would because
i turned against my family so i was
myself with a lot of use and so you're
kicked out at what age
i was kidnapped probably about
16 17 years old and i've had to work
ever since i was 19 like we had to pay
away did you finish high school oh yeah
you did yeah i went to college and stuff
like that
yeah
i believe in breaking the cycle
um
[Music]
but i still uh i stood up for my nieces
and nephews and um
there's a big news story here a couple
years ago about
a woman using a stun gun on a kid's and
that was my brother and my sister-in-law
died
and i was the only one in the family i
stood up for there's five of them i
stood up for all five of them because i
didn't want to see them go through abuse
like i grew up with uh where there was
locks on the refrigerators
i mean they even counted little debbie
cakes and stuff
if a pop was missing i'd get my ass
ripped
yeah so
i didn't watch my little niece and
nephew so i still i was the only one in
the whole family stood up for him and i
got
thrown out
and to this day my family didn't have
hardly anything to do with me to this
day
because i betrayed the family but my
nieces and nephews
i'm proud to see my
i'm a great grand
great
uncle my
niece the stun gun was used on was raped
talking to contact me the other night
and she had a little girl
and
i'm in contact with her so
yeah my
my life has not been easy
i had to cook math for my family
starting at the age of
11 12 i had to start cooking math that's
how i had to pay my weight your family
was selling crystal meth they were
making money by cooking it yeah
thank god i went to office of worry and
i went to college
so drug use is that something you guys
are involved in
druggies um i struggled with for many
years and i just recently got off a
couple months ago when i lost my leg
and i had to because it was starting to
really really affect my health like i'm
40 years old now
i lost my teeth this year and there's
many years of drugs
what drugs have you used
christian math and
age every once in a while but not
then i had to get off up because i can't
do it anymore because my body
my body's
i got a body of a 90 year old
and randy what to what about you
um i did like the first time i ever
tried crystal meth was when i was like
12 13 years old and then after that like
i did it then and maybe for that year
when i was i was in middle school
actually i did it then and i stopped and
then
like now and recently kind of i have
struggled through like heroin which i'm
still kind of battling with trying to
get off of it
honestly and so how do you guys support
yourself now
um
we have his mentor like his um family
friend growing up he pays our bills
pretty much pays our rent and everything
until he gets his disability
and in between that and food stamps and
stuff and whatever kind of way we can
hustle and kind of
you know not have to
[Music]
yeah
you ever get involved in like sex
working like that no i don't know i mean
i have whenever i was younger not
recently since i've been with him no but
you know there was a time when i would
you know like get him grinder and i had
guys that i would meet you know i had
sugar daddies and stuff like that and
john got some of a guy that would pay me
and stuff like that see well since
i mean i in the engagement we usually
you know gay people don't want to be
sleeping around
well
i was
as you say pool say ho at one time but i
never done sexual money
but i was a hoe
you know kind of [ __ ] if you don't my
language and
but ever since i got it was diagnosed as
being hiv positive i started an outlook
on stuff
i started waking up like i wake up every
day sick
from hiv was that right yeah and i don't
want to subject anybody to hiv
i refuse to how does that affect your
relationship with randy he has every
positive too he's the one that gave it
to him i mean yeah as far as we know but
i mean honestly it's a blessing in
disguise because we have each other you
know
it's nice to know that i have somebody
who doesn't you know judge me for it and
someone to stand by my side
and it's loyal to me you know i mean
so i used to i used to do insulin the
hypodermic needles and i went to my
doctors and i was like y'all got changes
because
well i looked out my window over here
one day and i saw this old woman and his
old man going through the dumpster
taking out needles like i've been doing
news i i was before my leg got cut off
and i i went out and i told him i said
y'all may not want to be taking my
needles i said that means happy positive
because i don't see nobody getting
infected so i went to my doctor's
and um i had them change it to the pens
that way i don't have to
they'll
it won't be on my conscience somebody
grabbed a needle from the dumpster and
got hiv due to me even though those that
i don't know is doing taking my needles
because that's a that's a if you don't
understand it's a hard
thing to carry boredom knowing that if
you you
gave some hiv i mean you changed
somebody's life
i mean like my life has changed
radically where
i'm going once or twice a month blood
work i mean not just your simple blood
draw
there's twenty thirty tubes of medicine
amount of bowels they take out of me the
medication is hoarse
the medication will make you sick
just
that's why i don't take my medicine a
lot because it makes me so physically
ill
so i don't want to subject anybody else
to this so i'm very cautious when it
comes in
if i can just stop it my needles even my
needles get stolen from the homeless
people coming out to my apartment they
were taking my years and he was stealing
my needles if i can just stop one person
from getting it i'm done a lifetime
i don't want just diseases
almost like my diabetes it's something i
don't know what's on anybody even people
i hate
i would never wish nobody on hiv hiv is
terrible
and i don't care what they say oh
there's medication to help you
all medication let me take some
medications horse
there's nothing bad once you take it and
get in your system and you're using
yourself taking it for a year and you
get the right one it's not that bad it's
made me sick every day for me i think it
depends on your body everybody's
different it's you know for each
individual honestly well last month i
got dinos with having morsa
and they put me in the hospital and um
everything went more so
in my bones that's what caused me my
mind
my
you know more so than
the infection insurance commerce is yeah
i got dinosaurs in my bone and it was um
a combination of having diabetes and hiv
and uh the antibodies they put me on i
had to take finnegan and um zofin
for
the anti
nauseams and i take both of them
together when they gave her i was on
24-hour antibiotics it's strong
antibiotic
it pulled my blood count down which i
had to sign a release because
this only antibiotic would fight it
where i was so infected with the melissa
that i feel it's pulling my blood count
down if you get your blood count the
white blood count cell count if it gets
down below 200
you go into the age
with my blood count it poured my blood
count all the way down to 212 214
meaning i only got 14 blood cell counts
white blood cell counts to fight
infections in my body
before i go into ace violence which
probably i've been out about a month and
a half from the hospital it's probably
it's probably turned into east valleys
right now so i'm fighting about all my
life more worse than
anything i've ever fought wasn't a drug
addiction it wasn't anything is that
your biggest fear right now my biggest
fear yes and then i have
extra stress about being thrown out on
the street like i am with
are you getting evicted from your place
mm-hmm he's already everybody evicted
today's d-day it's the last day we have
yeah i have a problem with me until i
got my leg cut off and it's just he just
doesn't want to
pay the thousands of dollars and make it
handicap successful even a store i mean
i don't know how he gets by with a store
not even have electronic doors for 88.
the american disabilities act of 1990 is
this the lowest point in your lives
no no i
how about you randy
um i can't even begin to even tell you
for sure what's the lowest point but
this is
nothing compared to some of the other
things i've been through honestly yeah
you guys have each other which helps me
exactly we have each other so it kind of
makes things easier honestly
this has been my lowest point losing my
leg
learning how to walk over everything
learn how to walk you know i got a
hospital i haven't learned how to pee
stuff in i got to get the rest of my
about my knee now cut off and i don't
i'm like
see if you cut off some more yet mm-hmm
because it said there's no infection in
his bones they somehow missed
this is the lowest point in my life
i think we've been through worse than
this
you go through like depression and
things like that mm-hmm yeah they're bad
really bad
imagine i'm 40 years old
going 40 years
alone in hawaii i could because you
honestly
after 40 years learning how to walk and
then you're walking and i have to learn
how to do everything or again when i had
to have somebody wipe my butt and
you know just stand me up to use the
bathroom you know can you imagine could
you how would you deal with that like
just gonna take it one day at a time
and that's what i'm hearing my faith in
god is strong but my faith is way like
i know bits of tdj taught us this is
only a test
and basically jake says big [ __ ] about
it charleston washington across things
so here here in appalachia does it make
it
you know the
the attitudes maybe a little different
than they are in other parts of the
country is it difficult to be an
interracial
gay couple mm-hmm i come from polka poco
west virginia
i don't race hysteria in this area
imagine growing up being gay
then you have ku klux klan people and
jamie over there knows the area come
from
imagine being gay let alone have an
attraction to black guys
yeah they have their ropes and their
cross is ready for you he's younger
like now now
today's age people might really look at
us it's different and they're really bad
eyelash that we're you know in a
relationship in this area like this
downtown we're we're like downtown but
if i take them over to my area which is
much more rural
i don't think so he has given his
opinion like he hasn't my mom's wife you
know what i'm saying he's never been
exposed to the type of people i was
raised around like i would never take
him around
people in my neighborhood jamie you know
what i'm talking about he thinks he
knows he thinks he knows
no
people have hidden covers people wear
sheepskins while i live i mean
yeah there's no way in hell i would ever
take him around my neighborhood in
daylight let alone in nighttime honestly
be honest what what was the best times
of your life
ready mm-hmm meeting him yeah waking up
every day him next to myself yeah i'm
saying kind of meeting each other
getting to know each other
it's been it's been pretty good honestly
it's nice to hear mm-hmm a lot of people
surprised like ups and downs but overall
a lot of people have surprised seven
years seven years a lot of people are
surprised like when they
find out where i'm from and then
find out how they black guys
how the hell did you make it you know
of course
and he knows one day he was at tutors
and nitro and i'm sitting outside and
talking to this guy and if you talk to
me i'm not you can't really tell i'm gay
okay unless you get to know him they
should get to know me and know me well
because i was raised in environment with
man you gotta be a man you can't
feminist no hell no you get you get you
hung across but we said tutors eating
breakfast one day and randy was in the
car and i sat and talked to this old
white dude old man
and he's like these damn quills and
these [ __ ] and they're sorry he was
getting on that's all things i'm talking
about
gay people being married stuff
and then out pops ran in the other car
and he comes up to his head babe
he gives me a kiss and that guy went
i was like oh
but
that's just a way i i've adapted to
people like both both sides of tracks
like i've been fat and i've been skinny
i know what it's like to be fat i don't
know where it's like to be skinny i'd
much rather be fat again and be honest
with you
what would you say is the most important
lesson you guys have learned in your
lives
other people
see less than he said
i showed other people love for other
people forgiveness
life of swords
tomorrow's never promised
that's about graves and definitely just
kind of
just learning to forgive people honestly
and learning to kind of just keep your
head up and just keep going honestly
very good
well randy
and stephen thank you so much for
sharing your stories you're very welcome
and i hope you guys find a new place and
i wish you the best of luck thank you
thank you